I’ve always been obsessed
with how things sound.
It’s the difference between a
great song and an iconic recording.
I am Mark Ronson.
And whenever someone sits
down to play me a song,
I’m already thinking
about the sound.
Be impressive.
Sound matters.
And when I first started out,
I wondered, how did they do that?
When rap songs started
having drum machines.
That was like, 'oh I gotta
get a drum machine.'
Just like that.
You can turn any
noise into music.
Just like that.
We’re constantly
searching for new sound.
I made a whole album
with one of these.
Where did you actually
sample the seagulls?
I think it's just me.
Pure genius Mark.
Pure genius, I meant.
These machines are used
to create the sounds of the people
that are not in the mainstream.
There’s only so much that
we can do with language.
The whole world
opened up.
You started to see
bedroom producers.
Can you do
a little editing?
The next person that is going to change
music has no idea how to play the guitar.
Is this allowed
to happen?
I’ve been doing it
wrong for thirty years!
I didn’t need words.
I just needed sounds.
This is a
Peavey Decade.
I can’t believe this is really
happening right now.
You can do anything
you want to do.
You start
obsessing over it.
It doesn’t have to
follow any format.
I believe in
happy accidents.
Only criteria is what?
It better be funky.
We’re just getting started.